thank you very much and it's very good
to be here you will find that I know
nothing about computer architecture I am
a physicist an electrical engineer who
works on hardware and yes I worked with
photons what am I going to tell you
today I'm not going to tell you to make
an optical computer I think that's
mostly a bad idea but as has already
been pointed out to you optics is very
good communications what I'm really
going to talk about today is why we need
to move over to using more optics
especially insight machines for the
communications primarily I think we
should move to all the interconnects off
the chip
from the edge of the chip we should
think about doing those in optics and
I'm going to give you the arguments for
that and as we know things like Dennard
scaling of indeed the specific way in
which we scaled silicon chips has also
ended but the interconnection scaling
actually ended a long time ago and we
have been living in a world that is like
Manhattan with a complete traffic jam
over the whole island we basically live
in that world all the time with
high-performance machines and the
reasons for that are not problems a
silicon they're problems of copper it's
the difficulty of making the connections
that is becoming more and more of the
problem and I do not know of any
physical way out of this without going
to optics without going to more optics
and the good news is that optics offers
us a few orders of magnitude of Headroom
both in the energy and in the density
for the connections the challenges the
technology is not necessarily easy but
we do not need any new physics in order
to do this and that's the essence of my
entire talk I could stop at this point I
probably want but that's what I'm going
to tell you this afternoon so as you see
I'm at Stanford University those of you
in this room probably have seen me
around many of you may have taken
classes from me and the title as you see
is saving energy and increasing density
and infamy
processing using photonics so first of
all although these slides may become
available to you anyway on some posting
I'm always very happy to send copies of
my slides out to anyone just send me an
email and most of this talk is based on
this paper and this is an open-access
paper so if you follow that DOI link
there you'll be able to get a copy of
this paper and I'm also happy to send
you a copy if you need it so here's the
summary of what I'm going to try to
cover I'm going to start with some
background on our growth in the use of
information now this is something that
changes all the time but there is no
doubt that our growth in the use of
information has been and continues to be
somewhat exponential and then I'm going
to talk about some limits to that and
the limits come primarily the ones I
will talk about from interconnect
density we cannot continue to scale the
amount of information that we get on and
off chips and from the energy involved
in information processing and here's
something that might come as a surprise
to you most of the energy in handling
information is in communications it's
not in logic and we're running up
against limits on energy and I'll just
show you some of those I'm the only way
to get rid of most of that energy is to
think about changing the way that we
send the information around so I'll show
you that and try to give you a sense of
that and then I'll get into the topics
about how optics can help with that why
it could help with that - first of all
eliminate the energies associated with
wires and secondly to solve the
interconnect density problem and a third
one is a little surprising it's to
eliminate unnecessary circuits and here
I mean the interface circuits that run
the links how are we going to use optics
to help with that that seems an unusual
thing to do the underlying goal of this
path that I'm laying out here is perhaps
that we would think of doing all
interconnects not just the long-distance
internet not just between racks and data
centers but all interconnects possibly
from the edge of the chip using
photonics
that we would transform the energy
involved in doing that from something
that is in the scale of one to ten Pico
joules per bit that's roughly what it
costs to send information from chip to
chip or inside racks just something
that's more like 10 to 100 femtojoules
per bid so that's two orders of
magnitude in reduction in that energy
and I'm also arguing that that energy is
really the dominant energy in online
information now if you're not used to
these numbers these prefix brief issues
here are ones that physicists and some
electrical engineers work with all the
time but of course if Pico Joe is
something that is basically a trillionth
of of a Joule
it might pen to work here get the
pointer Pikachu is about a trillionth of
virgil and a femme to jewel is a
thousand times smaller than that and
you're going to see throughout this talk
I will keep talking about Pico joules
and femtojoules the pica jewel as I say
is the characteristic energy maybe 1 to
10 Pico joules is the characteristic
energy required today to communicate a
bit of information on or off a chip and
that might seem a small number to you
but it is in fact a very large number
because we communicate so much
information and then I'm talking about
the notion that we might be able to take
two and two orders of magnitude out of
that energy by cutting over two more
optics then we get to the ten
femtojoules 150 Joule range this is the
supposedly the total energy to handle a
bit everything from the logic level here
to the logic level over there that's the
idea everything wall plug energy that's
involved in doing it ok so my other
argument is if we don't do this with
optics I do not see any other way of
doing it I don't think there's any other
technology sitting in the wings that
will get us out of this not RF wireless
it won't get ahead of this
superconductors will not get it get us
out of this I don't see any other
technology so optics as far as I
understand it is the only way we're
going to make substantial advances in
solving these two problems
so here is a graph I put this together
based on where other interesting paper
shouldn't use the laser pointer here
interesting paper from about 2011 maybe
it seems a little old now but this paper
looked at information it very generally
it looked at storage of information it
looked at communication of information
and looked at processing of information
and that includes everything like
sending newspapers or on on railway
trains it included everything that was
going on and much of this is not really
very surprising I used to work for a
telecommunications company AT&T and
round about the year 2000 was the
cutover that is when the internet
started to beat all telephone
communications it became the dominant
way of sending information and it is
these days the dominant way of sending
information overall and most of that
information is sent over most of the
distance that it travels on optical
fiber we could make many arguments as to
why we have the Internet today and it's
certainly true if we didn't have silicon
integrated circuits we wouldn't have the
internet but if we did not have optical
fiber we certainly would not have the
internet that's what enables us to send
vast amounts of information over vast
distances and it has its same Moore's
Law growth and capacity like the silicon
chip had for growth in its ability to
process information that has been a
remarkable development and I'll talk a
little bit more about that in a second
one thing I would just say to you if we
put our minds to it on one optical fibre
we could have everybody in the world
talking at once and get all of that
information over one optical fiber which
is the thickness of one human here I
don't have very many of those but that's
the that's the thickness of it that's
the level of the capacity of optical
fiber and it means that we're nowhere
close to running out of space to put
optical fibres in the ground we
basically run out of space and cities to
put roads we know that we're nowhere
close to running out of space to put
fibres in the ground where we do begin
to run into a problem even with fibers
is inside very dense information
processing systems like data centers
even there the fibers may not
but they're still a lot better than
wires so this was the cutter over as I
said round about the year 2000 and the
telecommunications is almost entirely
Internet the internet is this dashed
line here and then I've also plotted on
this same graph a completely different
thing I've plotted the growth in our
ability to community preventive
structures per second that we had
manufactured and installed of general
purpose processing units and on the face
of it this looks pretty good
so this blue line here also increasing
this nice big exponential rise here that
blue line looks as if it's parallel to
the red line and everything is good our
ability to calculate is just as good as
their ability to communicate they're
growing together actually that's not
true and where it completely breaks down
is inside the machines and we're
basically not able to keep up now these
numbers here that I'm showing you for
this first decade or so of this of this
century we were seeing 60 percent per
year growth in both the
telecommunications bandwidths being
deployed and our ability ability to
calculate and that corresponds to a
factor of a hundred in ten years now if
you look at a study as to how much
energy we were using to do this it's
quite a good European study down here
we're using something like five to ten
percent of all electricity to process
and communicate information well if you
have another factor of a hundred
increase in the communication and
processing of information then we need
1,000 percent of the current electricity
in order to handle it in other words if
we do not keep reducing the total energy
per bit to process and communicate
information we cannot keep scaling our
information processing under use of
information in the same kind of
exponential scale and in that sense
energy becomes a dominant limitation
have you talked to somebody who builds
data centers they will tell you that
they have to think an awful lot about
energy
and they built their own power plants
I've been all such a very good cooling
engineering very good electrical
engineer need to feed that feed the
power to the machines so there's an
energy problem with these systems we
have to do something if we're going to
continue to scale our ability to process
and communicate information solely based
on energy and the second point is we are
already at saturation in our ability to
communicate the information inside the
system thank you
this is a picture a map and I have to be
careful here not to put up a copyrighted
material this is certainly public domain
this is a very very old map and it's a
map of the first transatlantic
telecommunications link and that's from
1865 approximately the same year as
Maxwell's equations they think and I
can't show the the maps of the fibre but
the maps of the fibre around the world
look rather like this but with hundreds
and hundreds of cables all over the
place now there's interesting stories
behind this as somebody in Telegraph
cable people had already made cables for
example from England over to France that
doesn't have to go so far so they knew
about making submarine cables and they
thought what we'd really like one across
the Atlantic so they had a few attempts
at this and the first several attempts
failed one of them failed in a rather
amusing way they couldn't get enough
signal at the end of the line so they
kept up Putin kept on putting up the
voltage that they put on the line until
they got to two kilovolts they were
switching on and off two kilovolts to
send Morse code over this line and it
blew up the line and then they realized
they needed to do something a bit more
fundamental about it so then they went
and talked to somebody whom you will
have heard of perhaps either scientist
you've certainly heard of this person
but this person as an engineer figured
out first of all he figured out the
equations for propagating signals along
lines and figured that all out and he
told them they needed to use better
quality copper because they were getting
limited by the poor quality copper which
had two higher resistance and he also
invented the device that you put on the
far end of the line so it could pick up
very sensitive signals so you did
was two things and that made the whole
thing work and that person was Lord
Kelvin the same person who gives his
name to the scientific temperature scale
who worked on entropy and second law of
thermodynamics and all sorts of other
things but he was also very good
engineer and he was the person who
solved this problem of course when you
do that you end up with a pretty big fat
cable and here is a picture of the
people actually this one on the right is
the one that is for for the near the
shore because you need a thicker one has
to be more armored but the basic point
is you need a big fat cable in order to
do this and the reason for that is
because of the resistance and
capacitance of the cable you may
remember there was a thing long before
brexit there was a thing called the
British Empire and round about the turn
into the 20th century
the Brits managed to do something
remarkable they managed to get what they
call the thin red line which was a
continuous telegraph system that went
all the way around the world and they
did this based on signalling basically
using what McElveen had invented the
strip chart recorder the siphon recorder
so a little pain like we used in
seismographs today was invented by Lord
Kelvin and the operators who run this
could read these signals and
incidentally they had to get very good
at doing it and for those events of
signal processing these operators were
capable of doing deconvolution the knew
how to recognize on these signals what
was going on they can deconvolve the
impulse response of the line so they
could actually read more bits per second
than you could deduce just from simply
above and below the line kind of
signalling very good at it the longest
link in that line because it Brits had
had a minor problem with this place
called the United States of America
and that meant we could not go from like
San Francisco over to the other side of
the Pacific and so they had to go from
Vancouver to finding Island they had to
go from bum fields Vancouver Island
actually or then defining Island which
is in the middle of the Pacific Ocean
and that was about four thousand miles
long and what happens when you do that
is you run into the problem of the
resistive capacitive time constant of
the entire piece of copper and these
people were able using their
deconvolution by very skilled operators
to send the equivalent of seven bits per
second that was the capacity of that
light but you could get information down
it however this same problem does not go
away there's a basic problem with the
resistance and capacitance of electrical
lines and basically at least unless you
go to more sophisticated multi level
signaling and start building modem
circuits and things like that
the bit rate you can get down this line
is basically one for every RC resistive
capacitive thank Austin of the line and
that problem does not go away and so as
we look for example a hypothetical line
on a chip or something like that and the
one I've drawn here I've just drawn a
line on the right which is you know
there's some conductor above a ground
plane down here or a smaller version of
it over here on the left and the catch
with this is if you look at these two
lines if I take the line on the right
and I scale it down in all three
dimensions the resistive capacitive time
constant of it remains the same and
that's a basic scaling problem of
electrical interconnects and what in the
end it means is if you reach this sort
of RC limited capacity of these lines
and for short lines they tend to be RC
lines not LC lines if you reach that RC
limited capacity you can't get any more
information through the system by
shrinking it or by making it bigger it
makes no difference there's a hard wall
on information density and simple
electrical connections now you can do
things about this you can as I say go to
a multi-level signaling and go to modems
you can put in repeaters and the like
but those all have a circuit cost to
them but in general is a simple scaling
limit and as I say it's a limit that is
actually dimensionalized what's over on
the right-hand side here is
dimensionless the cross-sectional area
of the line divided by the square of the
length
dimensionless number and that's what is
saying that this limit is
scale-invariant if you've filled all the
space with wiring and you've reached the
maximum information you can get through
that it doesn't get any better if you
tried to shrink the whole thing I'll try
to make the whole thing bigger you've
reached a fairly steep steep wall and so
then lathe a the pre-fight sit in here
is about 10 to the 16 which might sound
a lot but you can check it out and that
pretty much gives you the capacity of a
coaxial line or a line on a chip pretty
much gives you the answer to that this
doesn't get any better strangely enough
if you go to inductive capacitive lines
it actually gets slightly worse which
isn't it be surprising so the simple
story is once wiring fills all space and
you're running it as fast as you can get
the signals down it you're more or less
had it there's not anything you can do
that substantially puts out the capacity
of that as I say you can start doing
multi-level signalling you can start
doing more sophisticated signal
processing on the line but that is
putting up the circuit cost and that
puts up the energy by the way now optics
is good because it doesn't have this
particular scaling limitation it
completely avoids it this scaling
limitation mostly comes from resistive
loss optics doesn't have that
incidentally as I said this problem is
not solved by going to superconductors
however and optics is a very small
wavelength the fact that it has a small
wavelength means that you don't have to
use metals to confine the radiation you
have to use metals in transmission lines
to stop the radiation leaking out the
metals have to give the very difficult
boundary conditions that keep the
radiation inside the wire the wavelength
of light is half a micron and that's
small enough you can use dielectric wave
guides which are generally larger than
the wavelength optical fiber is a good
example the active partly optical fiber
is about 10 microns and the overall
thing is 100 microns so the combination
of these two things means that optics
doesn't have this particular scaling
problem so that scaling limit that
electrical wiring runs into does not
exist in optical systems now here are
some pictures of wiring density this is
one that shows here the here are the
wiring layers on the top of the chip to
these telegraph poles
here the logic units are done at the
bottom here you can see some of these
little things down here called people
and that's taken pictures taken sometime
towards the end of the 19th century I
think in Manhattan that might be
Broadway basically what has happened
here is we have filled all the available
space with wiring and it's saturated you
can't get past that without changing
technology now there were a bunch of
things that people did back then in
order to do this the improved is
signaling down the lines but they also
had to go to switching technology to
optimize the use of lines and so on a
bunch of things they did but this
problem does not go away here's the
inside of a telephone exchange in the
early 1970s it's filled with
twisted-pair and I can't show the usual
pictures I like to show of wiring on
chips but to give you a sense the fabric
it is a supposed cross-section of a chip
is just a sketch of it supposed to cross
section if you cut through a chip
nearly all the fabricated white volume
in a chip is wiring it's not transistors
the transistors are so small that on a
scale like this you couldn't see them
the wiring layers on the surface of a
chip or something in the scale of five
to ten microns thick the transistors are
things that are in a scale of tens of
nanometers in size so nearly all the
fabricated volume is taken up by wiring
and this basically this the wiring
systems and chips basically satisfy this
limit that I've been talking about all
the time and this is some data from the
ITRs roadmap so those things have
changed character a little recently
because the the Moore's law is not
continuing in the same way but if you
took a simple-minded extrapolation from
like a 2007 chip you realize that
although perhaps the ability to process
which is the orange line here might
continue to grow on some kind of Moore's
Law Carver maybe it doesn't the
input/output rate certainly doesn't you
run out of pins and you don't want to
clock them any faster because you've
reached this particular wiring limit
that I'm that I'm talking about and this
causes what people in architecture knows
is a byte per flop problem you would
like to get one byte of information out
of memory for every floating-point
operation that you were going to perform
but in general in computer architecture
you can't do that and that ratio is
probably getting worse as I understand
it all right so let's move from the
density problem which I see can be sold
by optics and I'll see a little bit more
about that later
move from the density problem to the
energy problem here's a list of energies
per bit as we look through the Internet
and it took me a while to compile these
numbers is rather difficult to nail down
but they're quite surprising in many
ways first of all the worst of all is
your cell phone the cell phone uses an
energy that's in the scale of micro
joules to tens of micro Joule per bit
overall in the system that's the energy
that it takes to send wireless
information in an act of your cell phone
it's on that scale and that's orders of
magnitude larger than any of the other
scales so one might reasonably ask if
we're going to 5g and we're going to
have a thousand times more bandwidths we
may have a problem here with energy and
I haven't seen people discuss that in
many great depth but maybe that will
come right now if we look at the
internet pretty quickly we we try to get
out of wireless in the RF sense and get
into optical backhaul or maybe you have
a modem on on your wall that's connected
directly to an optical fiber that at the
moment still takes a fair amount of
energy at some 10 watt box and because
we're not sending a very large amount of
information through it at the moment the
bit rates are perhaps not yet that high
it becomes the next largest amount of
energy per bit in in the Internet to
send information but the next one might
begin to surprise you you might think
that the next largest energy will be the
long-distance communication of
information it isn't so the wavelength
division multiplexed lengths of WDM
stands for 20 hops over a wavelength
division multiplexed link and the
Internet is something that will consume
a few nano joules of energy but more
energy is dissipated inside the Cisco
rotors and that is energy inside the box
it's the wiring inside the box is where
the energy is being dissipated the Cisco
router or whatever manufacturer it is
that is routing the information that
comes in off one optical fibre and
sending it on
now us become insight the information
processing system for example look at
this number here the energy and DRAM
cell to store a bit of information it's
probably something in the scale of a 10
M to jewels 20 tempted jewels the energy
to communicate to an off chip DRAM is 5
Pico joules
it's nearly three orders of magnitude
larger now there are many things one
would do as a result we put the memories
close to processors possible well that
is good news but the energy required to
fetch bits from some other chip is
basically this number I've been talking
about it's a number of Pico joules per
bit and I've also shown here a
characteristic number for communicating
off chip is a in the scale of Pico
joules to maybe tens of Pico joules when
we look at the energy for logic
operations themselves they're not so bad
even an entire floating-point operation
per bit is probably only of the order of
a hundred femtojoules so an entire
floating point operation 64 bit might be
6 pica joules or something per bit
therefore a hundred hundred femtojoules
in the calculation and you know running
an individual CMOS gate is probably
something down in the scale of a number
of femtojoules would be ten femtojoules
maybe vast a hundred other jewels Auto
being a 10 to the minus 18 joules but
once we come to make a gate and connect
over to the adjacent gate the numbers
tend to go up in that so that's most of
the connection number that gets you
these energies here I'm communicating
across a chip is a better part of a Pico
Joule so coming off the chip is a number
of Pico joules communicating across the
chip is the order of Pico Joule all of
these energies are much larger than the
logic energy inside the chip transistor
energy inside the chip let me just show
you some data rates at different lens
scales it's very difficult to get firm
numbers and these but I think the orders
of magnitude make some sense to us
so one estimate by Cisco of end-to-end
Internet traffic so that's not the stuff
that sort of flows around between the
data centers as well but end user to end
user they estimated a number of about
280 terabytes per second and that's a
number that I've already mentioned
because that's the data rate if everyone
in the world is talking on the telephone
all the time that's roughly the data
rate associated with doing that as I
said you can't incidentally get all that
down one fibre if everyone is it the two
ends of the fiber if you look inside a
data center it's again it's difficult to
get numbers to 2015 Google published a
number that their rack direct traffic
was probably in the scale of a pity bit
per second so 10 to the 15 bits per
second it's probably quite a lot larger
than that now if you look inside chips
again people don't normally publish
these numbers but I find one chip that
did the edge edge numbers that I could
get data rate that you could in
principle drive off a chip by running
all the pins at their maximum data rate
frequencies would be in the scale of
terabytes per second and if you look
inside the chip the network bandwidth
inside the chip are many terabytes per
second possibly tens of terabytes per
second the conclusion out of this is
that though there's a lot of information
goes over long distances there is
massively more information at short
distances a few chips could generate
enough data to saturate our end-to-end
data traffic on on the Internet there's
just massively more information at
shorter distances
here's an old graph that Krishna
Saraswat put this one together I think
back about in the early 2000s even by
2002 50% a microprocessor power was in
interconnects and it's probably going up
since that time includes the clocking
system part is financially significant
anyone who puts together data centers or
knows this that the cost of powering a
server over its lifetime is comparable
to the manufacturing cost of the server
question for you how much energy does it
take to perform a Google search so
you've queued up your search searching
for some kind of cat videos or something
on the Internet you're ready to hit
Enter how much energy are you going to
dissipate in the Internet when you hit
Enter so I want to take bids on this how
many will bid me a milli Joule anyone
bid a million
was a milli Joule gonna do it is that
what you're gonna March as a milli Joule
you're gonna use a whole milli Joule to
do this 10 mil a milli Joule all right
we have a millage it will anyone raise
me in a million Joule ten millions will
anyone give me 10 10 100 all right the
answer is one kilojoule and if you don't
believe me google it because that number
actually comes from somebody at Google
there's real energy dissipated in the
internet and that is dissipated mostly
in the data centers and the robots no
Google does a very good job of trying to
make these things as efficient as
possible this is not a fault of Google
that that's the answer to this question
but it's significant energy and you know
there are pictures art they are off
cooling towers at data centers with
steam pouring out of them and this is
perfectly perfectly real and if you're
worried about whether you should work on
interconnects or work on solar power
well solar power is fantastic but we're
already dissipating more power and
interconnects than all of the solar
power generation this is an
environmentally significant number
anyway my major conclusion out of this
is that though it does take more energy
to send information over longer
distances there's just massively more
information sent at shorter distances so
that most of the energy dissipation in
our handling of information is in
shorter links inside machines it could
be on the chip but the ones I'm going to
talk about about mostly going off the
chip to solve some problems and the
reason for this is fairly simple we
don't need to go through all of these
numbers but a key point is that the
capacitance per unit length of all
electrical lines is the same it's about
two Pico farad's per centimeter give or
take a factor of two or so and that's
because you remember from your
electromagnetism that the capacitance of
a coax line only depends logarithmically
on the ratio of the inner to outer
conductor sizes basically when your
lines capacitance is only
logarithmically dependent on the
relative dimensions it doesn't depend on
the absolute
dimensions of everything a 50-ohm line
has two Pico farad's per centimeter
capacitance an 80 nanometer line on the
chip has a comparable number per
centimeter so we are stuck with the
capacitance of electrical lines there's
essentially nothing we can do about it
and therefore if you had some line that
was communicating for the sake of
argument and we see a volt I mean nobody
quite works for the Volt but if you had
a 1 volt signal across a chip that's
about or centimeters in size then that's
where your Pico Joule comes from so once
you start sending electrical signals
over centimeters scale distances you
start running into Pico joules on tens
of pica joules of energy and that's the
basic explanation for the energy
dissipation in electrical interconnects
and another way of putting it is if you
look at a logic gate the wiring
capacitance from may be a little bit
more than one gate length is comparable
to the capacitances inside the gate so
the logic energy which is primarily to
charge and discharge capacitances the
device itself becomes comparable to the
energy required to send the information
a gate or a few gates further away and
since mostly we send the information
further than that then most of the
energy dissipation is in wiring now I'm
not advocating we cut over to optics on
the chip the wires are still the best
way to do it on the chip but we see the
problem that the energy dissipation is
mostly in the communications and if you
want to get a number in your minds again
it's the same number I'd be mentioning
this is a 208 ofits per micron or 2 Pico
farad's per centimeter is the
capacitance of wiring and an order of
magnitude number that you might think of
is that every time you touch a bit in a
CMOS circuit you're probably dissipating
fanta joules of energy on the average is
that 100 femtojoules well it could be if
you're going a long distance if you're
really really really local and it's just
going to the very next gate then maybe
it's less than FM that you'll maybe it's
a hundred other joules but in your mind
think about this number that I am going
to every time I touch a bit in some
processes some calculation anything that
I run I'm dissipating possibly the
joules maybe 10 of energy
and I do that and that's important
because you might think I can solve all
these problems I can go to better
signalling so I don't have to put such
large voltage Eastern lines I'll go to
better signalling let's put in some
amplifiers and I'll start doing time
multiplexing to get a capacity up well
in time multiplexing think about how
many times you touch the bit in order to
time multiplex different streams and you
have to buffer it to do clock clock and
data recovery and you're moving these
bits around and shift registers and your
multiplexers are running at very high
speed so it tends to cost more energy
the time multiplexing circuits to drive
time multiplexed on information aren't
offline so that it's optical or
electrical those circuits take Pikachu
less per bit because they have to touch
the bit multiple times in in the whole
process and the receiver amplifiers you
might put in there to work with smaller
signalling levels those things take
Pikachu lab it to run in practice so
there's a real difficulty in getting
past the Pikachu per bit level charging
the wire is taking a speaker joules per
bit running the circuits that might you
be amplifiers or running the clock and
data recovery running any time
multiplexing so we're getting the
bandwidth up every one of those is
taking energies that are of the order of
Pico joules and that's why it's very
hard therefore to get past this in this
number so my argument is that the
dominant energy dissipation is probably
charging and discharging wires inside
machines it's not long-distance it's not
the logic it's the charging and
discharging of wires so how can we get
around that well I don't want to bore
you with too much optics but I'll run
through these arguments reasonably
quickly here so one way to get around
the charging and discharging the lines
is to stop using lines and if we go to
optics there's a very neat trick in
optics and the bottom line in optics is
you don't have to charge the line you
just have to charge the photo detector
and I'll explain that it's sometimes
called quantum impedance conversion it's
actually a piece of quantum mechanics
it's actually the very first piece of
quantum mechanics it's the photoelectric
effect discovered by Heinrich Hertz
seen Hertz in 1885 so maybe we should
stop the
that and the key trick for that is as I
said I think we don't need to look at
all the details here when you work with
a light beam you're not measuring the
classical voltage in the electromagnetic
wave you're counting the photons and
that means that fundamentally you can do
an effective impedance conversion so the
electromagnetic way of going in free
space we can we do it classically if we
like for example take a one nano watt
light beam to the sake of a calculation
the classical voltage in that within
pedis of free space of 377 ohms is about
six hundred micro volts but if I take a
one nano watt light beam and shine ants
a photo detector and suppose that I can
put something like a 1 g gold load on it
the one Nana watt light beam would
generate of the order of a nano amp
which basically means I could drive the
diode in to forward bias or change the
voltage across it by some good fraction
of a volt I'm not measuring the
classical voltage in the beam and that's
one key reason why optics can ultimately
save as energy in connections we don't
need to be working with large classical
voltages in the electromagnetic wave it
doesn't need to be the logic level
voltage it doesn't even have to have a
voltage by the way it's a separate issue
but the key now is that we have to keep
the capacitance of this entire system
low enough that it's worth it so if the
capacitance of this system is Pico
financed then forget it because we're
going to have to charge bigger filings
to a volt and we're not any ahead of the
game about the Pico joules again so a
key point is if the optoelectronics is
going to help with this energy problem
then we have to have very low
capacitances in the optoelectronics oh
and the opto electronic devices need to
be efficient however we do have fairly
efficient devices in the lab and we do
have low energy devices in the lab we
don't have to invent fundamentally new
devices here so we have to reduce the
energy in up to electronic devices and
so that the energy to send and receive
the optical signal is not greater than
the energy it would have had to have
used to charge the while in the first
place and that's one reason why I'm not
pushing to put their stuff as on chip
connections that's the hardest
comparison because the wires are
shortest and wires still work pretty
on chip but once you get off chip you're
trying to deal with this Pikachu lor
tens of Pikachu number so as people who
work as engineers who worked on opto
electronic devices we want to push the
operating energies of the opto
electronic devices down to c10
femtojoules or something like that or
sub 10 femtojoules but actually we can
do that it's kind of hard with lasers
but we can make pretty good modulators
that do that and we also want to make
sure we're not blowing the whole thing
on the capacitance of the wire that
connects the photodetector
to the receiver or to the logic circuit
we have to keep that really short so the
capacitance of that wire isn't too much
and that means we have to integrate and
that's where the technological challenge
comes we have to work with opto
electronic devices on the transmitter
and that are probably different from
what we've been using in the past we
can't just use the long-distance
telecommunications lasers we have to go
to some other technologies but these are
all demonstrated in the lab we've
demonstrated some here and we need to do
a pretty good job at integration
basically if we don't want to incur more
than a femtofarad of additional
capacitance our photo detector has to be
within five microns of the transistor to
which it's connected because we have 200
out of farad's per micron of capacitance
and electrical wiring and that means the
photo detector has to be right on top of
the chip or ideally and beside the
transistors that's harder to do it'd be
good enough at the photo detectors right
on top of the chip and top of the wiring
layer then you've got five microns to
get down to the transistors that's about
a femto farad capacitance and that that
that would work so let me just give you
some orders of magnitude on capacitance
numbers a conventional
telecommunications photo detector might
have a Pico fire the capacitance why
because the capacitance of one cubic
micron of semiconductor is about a
hundred ATO files and if you have a
hundred by a hundred micron photo
detector then that's a Pico farad
because you get a hundred by hundred
cubes of 100 805 capacitance however if
you put the detectors make them small 5
micron detectors these were done the
CMOS a while ago for femto farad's
that's not useful to us because CMOS
silicon
does not absorb in the wavelengths where
we want to do most of our connections
which are mostly an infrared but as a
detective it works just fine here's our
wiring capacitance again FET input
capacitance these are things that are
intrinsically in the scale of tens to
maybe hundreds of other fires
so that's comparable to these numbers
and as I say hunter data files for cubic
micron is a good number to keep in your
head but what this means is if we were
to get to the capacitance numbers we're
looking at and the capacitance numbers
we're looking for at the receiver and in
particular are of the order of a FEM to
farad total we need micron scale devices
they don't have to be deeply deeply sub
micron micron scale devices for the
detectors and within microns of the
transistors so this is not a ridiculous
thing to ask of integration technologies
but it still means you have to generate
an integration technology to get to it
now here's a modulator device that Jim
Harris his group some collaborations
that me have made a few years ago this
is the best optical output device on
silicon in my humble opinion this for
purposes of persuading the contract
monitors you can sell this thing as
being below of m2 jewel more honestly
it's about seven femtojoules when you
include everything else you might have
to throw in but this is without you know
really trying it's without really going
down to very small skills that one could
use and so the idea of a 10 m2 jewel
device on silicon integrated with
silicon is perfectly real at least in a
laboratory demonstration sense and you
can talk about doing some other things
so some talk about doing nano metallics
or sometimes called plasmonics and
that's an interesting thing but
essentially this is doing RF circuits
about optical frequencies so you can
make coplanar strip lines and optics
with an 80 nanometer gap those actually
work but you can only go about 10
microns and those they're pretty lossy
you can make Hertz dipole antennas and
this is a Hertz dipole antenna that we
made in collaboration this is using a
technique that Jim Plummer had come up
with I see Jim sitting over there
growing germanium on silicon so we use
Jim's technique gruesome germanium on
silicon
this is none of this was done by me
germanium and silicon and then we turned
that into a tiny little photo detector
with a hearts dipole antenna connected
to it to funnel the light into the
little germanium photo detector and that
actually works and this is a zooming in
on the chip here here is the line of
germanium using Jim's technique grown on
the surface of the chip from a seat
point here and then on top of that you
make a tiny little Hertz dipole antenna
here are the arms of the antenna and
this is the the feed gap of the antenna
these are these don't matter much for
the antenna strangely no you can
actually make that thing and we did that
a few years ago you can use nano
metallic techniques in order to
concentrate the light even further and
that might be an interesting future
direction though interestingly enough
you don't even have to do that to get to
the numbers I'm thinking about so
there's a bit more Headroom there if you
get really exotic and these antennas do
actually benefit the performance of the
detector even though they're a bit lossy
so these things are about 139 meters
long and they're pretty much Hertz
dipole antenna now this is where I go
completely off the map and I go into an
idea that people will think is
ridiculous we figured out then how to
make the opto electronic devices in
principle we somebody is going to do a
good job in the integration technology
we're going to put these things on top
of the chip and those devices are gonna
run the FEM to farad capacitance season
they're gonna run the 10 M to joules of
energy fact we can actually see how to
do but remember there are all these
other energies involved in driving a
link so if we do this conventionally we
end up with a receiver amplifier in
front of the photo detector that
dissipates energy the best ones I've
seen of amplifiers are done in the
hundreds of femtojoules per bit level
that's still way too much and even worse
are things like time multiplexing
circuits I mentioned this before but if
you decide you have to go to time
multiplexing circuits to put more
information into the same length whether
it's optical are electrical you end up
dissipating a lot of energy
do that and you also need so that's the
serialization deserialization you need
to recover the clockface from most links
you also may have to do clock
distribution and those things are
blowing your whole budget those things
are taking pika joules of energy so is
there any way to get past those and this
is where what I'm talking about gets
ridiculous to people who use the normal
electronic world this would be very
scary and close to insane what I'm going
to propose now so bear with me well the
first thing we can do is we can get rid
of the receiver amplifier we don't need
to have a receiver amplifier in our
optical link the kind of energy we're
going to get at the of our optical link
at the end of our optical link is
perhaps going to be a bit of FEM to
Joule of optical energy that's of the
order of 10,000 photons or so it's quite
a lot of photons so we don't get into
statistics of photons per Sounion
statistics of photons that doesn't come
up as it's quite a lot of photons to
people in telecommunications that's
actually quite a lot of photons if you
put that into a conventional photo
detector this is back to the integration
question do it it's a conventional one
picofarad photo detector then those
thousand photons they give you a
thousand electron 10000 photons they
give you ten thousand electrons they
have to discharge the capacitance of the
photo detector if it's a one Pico fired
photo detector then you get 1 millivolt
out of that it's not good you know if
you go to a simple integration
technology like solder bump bonding the
capacitance involved there is probably
about 30 femto farad's or something like
that that gets you 33 millivolt signal
again you're going to need to build a
receiver amplifier but if you get to one
FEM to farad
total capacitance on the front end then
you can generate basically a logic swing
so it's possible to get rid of the
receiver amplifier and get rid of those
hundreds of femtojoules topeka joules of
energy per bit and that's good news so
we can probably do that that's not the
insane bit here as I said you know you
propose integrating this this is the
most extreme version I've shown here
where I put that the photo detectors
right beside the FinFET this is a very
extreme and actually in this case I'm
actually bringing light in and I'm used
nah no metallic concentration to feed
these things into you know sub hundred
nanometer scale things that's the most
exotic but you don't actually have to do
that if you put the photo detector
system on top of the metal there it may
be good enough so the photo detector
thing is not the insane bit but the
insane bit is this one so I want to get
rid of time multiplexing and I want to
get rid of clock and data recovery
because those operations are taking me
pika joules for every bit I'm sending on
an off the chip could I possibly do that
well you cannot do it with wires and you
cannot do it with wires because the time
delay on wires is not predictable and
the reason why the time delay in wires
is not predictable to the scale of a
clock cycle is because of the
temperature coefficient of the
resistivity of copper so the signal
coming down the line first of all it
broadens out from a nice sharp pulse to
a very squidgy kind of thing because of
the dispersion on the electrical line
and if you have a variability in the
resistivity of copper then the slope of
this rising edge changes with
temperature and that means you cannot
find a decision point in here whose
timing is precise optics doesn't have
the pulse dispersion and optics also
doesn't have the temperature coefficient
of the delay that is nearly as bad as
this in optics over a 100 degree
temperature variation the time delay
over 10 meters of optical fiber varies
by only about or 10 picoseconds and in
free space you don't get much
temperature variation at all and in a
signal delay so optics could give you
calculable signal delays and if you're
only talking about some small fraction
of a clock cycle which is what we in the
slop we allow anyway in logic circuits
then you only need to get the the
lengths of the optical paths right
within centimeters and we could
construct the company tomorrow that
would sell you optical fibers that were
cut to Precision's of a centimeter
that's not hard to do that's a pretty
easy job to do
so we're contemplating a system here in
which when you build a system you
actually fix all of the delays in the
system and you
some to integer numbers of clock cycles
then you never have to do clock face
recovery on the system and it's pretty
easy in optics to distribute the clock
frequency and that's not a hard thing to
do and obvious can do that but shortfall
sees that you very precise timing so
that's part of it but I'm also going to
throw away time multiplexing if I throw
a time multiplexing I don't have enough
lines if I'm not gonna run it 100
gigabits per second on these lines these
thousand or 100 lines how am I going to
get enough information going around the
system well that's where we get to
another degree of freedom we have not
yet exploited in optics free space so
your rods and cones in here of a few
million pixels in them and you can image
this room with a fairly simple piece of
optics you actually have millions of
channels coming into your your eyes
optics has lots of spatial degrees of
freedom and so the insane idea is let's
run everything at the chip clock
frequency and just choose lots and lots
and lots of free space optical channels
and then we don't have to do time
multiplexing now that's a radical idea
and most people are used to electronic
systems playing this extremely scary
I'm just gonna have a thousand channels
flowing through free space a hundred
thousand channels flowing through the
free space how am I going to sort those
things again it's called the Lance
optics actually works and we were
systems made in the 1990s and research
that worked with of the 65,000 light
beams and the things work just fine now
this is radical but it's not that hard
to do in optics we've been able to work
with arrays of light beams and optics
it's fairly easy to generate large
arrays of light beams in optics news
things all diffractive optics generators
we can work with large arrays of optical
beams and that would mean we did not
have to do time multiplexing and that
will get rid of these other pika joules
of energy and if you really wanted to
get rid of those final pika joules of
energy associated with the time
multiplexing then this is 1 degree of
freedom we've not not used yet
so let me give you a little bit of
optical physics here the number of
channels that you can have limited by
diffraction between two surfaces of
areas you know nor ETA are transmitted
in your receiver area there are other
simple formula this is the diffraction
limit it's a product of the two areas
divided by the square of the distance
between them and divided by the squared
of the wavelength and what does that
mean it means if I'm looking over to Jim
they are sitting he's about ten meters
away from me and Jim holds a telephoto
lens up a normal camera telephoto lens
and I hold a normal camera a telephoto
lens up we have approximately 1 million
channels that piece of optics limited by
diffraction will handle a million
channels it's not even that hard to make
the lenses that do that there's nothing
like the you know the 64 million pixels
that you're routinely playing about with
or something like this
these are astonishing pieces of free
space optics by the way just astonishing
pieces of design but because you make so
many of them on you can charge a lot for
them you can do a really good job in the
optics in here this is free space optics
but I don't know how many tens of
millions of pixels now inside here we
know how to do optics so that's one
concept and if we come down to shorter
scale suppose we're going to communicate
between two chips well that's not nearly
as much area we might only want to work
with a few square millimeters of area on
the chips to generate the arrays of
light beams I mean what might want to
put them centimeters apart how many
channels can we do then the answer is of
the order of tens of thousands of
channels so millimeters of square
millimeters of area and centimeters of
separation like going chip-to-chip could
handle thousands or tens of thousands of
channels and that's where you get the
degrees of freedom so this as I say it
seems fairly insane we can draw out the
optical systems as I say these optical
systems have been made in the lab many
times back especially in the 90s around
the early 2000s and then they were kind
of literally put on the shelf but these
are the kinds of systems this idea here
and going from one chip over to another
chip this is not a waveguide in between
it's just a piece of solid plastic or
glass just for
mechanical rigidity so that that's
that's the concept here this is where we
get the other degrees of freedom in
order to stop ourselves having the time
multiplex and this is the part that is
close to insane
to most people but not to optics people
politics people look at this yeah I'm
doing something like this is more a
question of deciding you want to
engineer it and setting up the team to
do it
this is not like germinating the next
generation of silicon technology it's
much easier than that and just to think
about it for a minute as I say it's
quite easy to generate very large arrays
of light beams tens of thousands is not
that hard but we've been doing it for
over 30 years it's not that hard to line
up an array of light beams it's not like
aligning ten thousand beams it's at
aligning one beam where you also have to
deal with an angle so the whole array
you have to get the rotation angle a
whole array right and you have to get
the dilation of the whole array right so
there's another couple of degrees of
freedom I think we can do that and if
you want to think about a servo to
optical system that works to submicron
for less than a dollar take apart you
remember these things called CD players
I'll take those things apart that's a
spinning disc and this thing remains
active alignments is serve out but it
can do it
submicron alignment we could make this
optics it's a matter of just deciding to
do it and free space arrays actually
obey something called Fermat's principle
and that means that all the path lines
are actually equal and free space
imaging at least if you do it right so
hypothetically then we would have some
array of these are called grating
couplers they would send light beams in
and out of the surface of the chip
here's a hypothetical one and ten by ten
micron optical paths millimeters of area
that can handle of the order of a
thousand channels and I'll show you a
bigger picture of this here but here's a
strawman architecture so what I would do
is I would take my chip as usual and
you're seeing the cross section of the
chip here we'll just go to the next one
it's a bigger picture see the
cross-section of the chip here I already
showed you something out this in fact I
had stolen this diagram to make the one
I show there
here's the cross-section of the wiring
leader of the chip on top of that
widening layer I put a photonic slayers
this is silicon photonics a silicon
waveguides this is a technology that
exists and is used quite a lot now
silicon photonics that is waveguides I
could put my modulators in there I think
I would have to add better modulators
that have to do something like the ones
I was showing you which would take a bit
of technological effort possibly I can
put the photo detectors up here or maybe
I can put the photo detector stand
beside the transistors ISM as in this
picture here so the notion this is a
strawman
it's a silicon chip and on top of that
chip I put a photonic Slayer and in that
photonic Slayer I put a bunch of wave
guides I possibly put photo detectors I
think I'll put modulators up in there to
turn on and off light beams and then as
I come up to the larger size scales here
I imagine that I'm going to collect
these various couplers into
two-dimensional arrays like this and
send these arrays on and off the chip
with the kind of optics that I'd been
talking about here and I may also be
generating a rays of light beams to send
onto the chip somewhere else and
incidentally I can also bring off fibers
here if I want to this is a strawman it
would take some technological effort but
this strawman without inventing anything
new I can reasonably argue if I
engineered it fairly well I can hit ten
fifty joules per bit total energy but
that's my argument I think the physics
works I don't say the technology is all
there but it doesn't require that we
invent anything new in order to do it so
there is two orders of magnitude of
Headroom sitting there for us and the
energy and I believe also in the density
as I say we do need some technology
stepping back a little bit here some of
my colleagues see Ariel and a Vuckovich
works on some very cute nanophotonics
devices and we kind of need some of
those because we need to make better
beam couplers so one of the hidden
problems in optics is making good beam
couplers and you might think this is
straightforward I take all this light
here I put it into a piece of glass it's
not all a piece of glass I've coupled it
no you have to get the beam shape right
as well so it's not just a question of
having the loss in the glass or the
waveguide
slow enough you actually have to match
the beam shape because you're coupling
into a mode and getting that so the loss
of those couplers is done at percents
rather than decibels is actually a very
tricky task and that's one of the things
that optics needs to work on it and it's
been needing to work on that for 40
years by the way but nanophotonics
techniques exploiting ability of silicon
technology to make structure stone in
the hundred nanometer scale is actually
coming up with some interesting ideas in
there so I'm claiming on my stroma and
here I think I can see how one can
engineer without getting really extreme
I could engineer a 10 M 2 Joule profit
system as opposed to the pica Joule per
bit systems were looking at that that's
my core argument really all right I
think we're getting to the end here and
running out of time so just let me throw
up a few conclusions on this what you
may be well regard fairly as a
speculative talk but I think I've tried
to illustrate that information
processing is being limited by density
of connections on by energy of
connections these are major issues they
have almost nothing to do with the
silicon transistor technology that's not
the problem in this aspect of this way
of looking at systems and I argue that
optics can help solve both of these
problems and there's a couple of orders
of magnitude of Headroom in here for
them to do that but it would need some
technological work and we would in the
end have to start thinking physically
about the systems in somewhat different
ways and that's definitely definitely
challenging my goal as I said is to try
to get the thing whole system down to
something on the scale of 10 to 150
joules to a bit instead of 1 to 10
figure joules per bit for the off chip
connections that's the argument the
challenges here are ones of integration
of the technology we need very low
capacitance integration many low loss
coupling a good piece of news out of
that is if you work on these problems
and people I think will pay for them
anyway because people would love for
example of low loss couplers it helps
all kinds of optical systems including
rather conventional fiber based systems
though it would be a good thing
I think the integration of photo
detectors and the like and the
generation of low-energy opto electronic
devices those are all thing
that we want anyway or a radical step
would be whether we cut over to that
free space optics but I think it would
take less money to generate this whole
infrastructure than it would take to
generate the next level next generation
of silicon integrated circuit technology
I think it would cost less than that I
don't know and there's some radical
steps involved here especially if we go
to this it's going to free space system
do we go to synchronous systems I claim
I think we could actually do that and
then it becomes a question of how much
we are prepared to invest in how soon
were prepared to invest it and that's a
non-trivial issue and I don't want to
oversell this I'm really selling a good
news message there's two orders of
magnitude of headroom here guys in the
interconnect density and in the energy
and it's a question of how soon we're
going to make that that change but the
good news is that those orders of
magnitude of Headroom are sitting there
and we don't have to invent anything
fundamentally new to get to them and
with that I will stop and take any
questions thanks very much
[Applause]